[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio rosa
pérez más de urosa vamos a abrir esta
revista de prensa con el artículo
economy sobre el primer avión que
traslada forzosamente a solicitantes de
asilo del reino unido hasta ruanda bueno
esto ya raul exactamente qué tema tan
complejo y tan polémico empecemos por
una cuestión digamos del concepto y de
definición porque la prensa está
hablando a menudo de deportaciones
cuando habla de este tipo de vuelos sin
embargo veamos la definición de la rae
para las deportaciones y habla de que
una deportación de un extranjero a su
país de origen es digamos a lo que se
refiere este concepto no devolverlo tras
la denegación del asilo o como
consecuencia de su expulsión sin embargo
estos vuelos a ruanda no son
deportaciones en el sentido de que las
personas digamos que estarían siendo
trasladadas a ruanda no son
necesariamente ruandeses no es una de
las claves de la vulneración de los
derechos humanos digamos
y británica que por otro lado no dista
tanto de otras leyes que de otros
acuerdos digamos que ha aprobado por
ejemplo la unión europea con turquía sin
embargo claro aquí lo que es tan
escandalosamente evidente es que pues
9.000 kilómetros separan londres de
kigali en cambio cuando la unión europea
externaliza en la gestión migratoria por
ejemplo con turquía habla a la prensa o
digamos las propias instituciones
europeas pues de retornos en frontera o
de devoluciones en caliente como
decíamos estas expulsiones han sido
criticadas tanto por organizaciones de
defensa de los derechos humanos como por
naciones unidas pero ya digamos al
margen de la vulneración de los derechos
humanos lo que the economist titula es
que las deportaciones a ruanda no
detendrán a los refugiados que intentan
llegar al reino unido no básicamente
desde un ángulo más digamos de
eficiencia de la política dice the
economist que la migración clandestina a
través del canal de la mancha es difícil
de vigilar pero existe precisamente por
la vigilancia por las políticas no lo
que se habla pues el caso de la
migración y en otros ámbitos pues que
digamos aplicar una política restrictiva
no acaba con una migración sino que la
vuelve más insegura dice the economist
que el año pasado más de 28.000 personas
llegaron a reino unido- clandestinamente
a través del canal de la mancha y que al
menos 45 murieron o desaparecieron en el
cruce y hay que tener en cuenta que la
mayoría de las desapariciones no se
pueden ni siquiera monitorear y ya para
terminar en relación a esto que apunta
the economist pues que digamos la
política que se ha aplicado con los
refugiados de ucrania por parte de la
unión europea que ha permitido que es
que les ha dado visados de trabajo
temporales o permisos de residencia pues
habría podido hacer abrir los ojos
respecto a que es mejor para todo el
mundo particularmente por los derechos
de las personas refugiadas pues tener
permisos de residencia de trabajo poder
vivir una vida digna en la legalidad y
no tener que digamos sobrevivir en la
clandestinidad o morir en el viaje como
lo resuelto en la prensa británica rosa
pues admira la prensa británica
curiosamente no lleva digamos este tema
en portada al menos no la mayor de los
periódicos si lo hace de independent con
esta imagen que vale más que mil
palabras y de esta imagen hemos
destacado precisamente el cartel que
lleva a este hombre aquí detrás esta
pancarta que habla de tráfico de
refugiados por parte del gobierno y lo
queríamos destacar porque la palabra
precisamente tráfico de personas se
equipara a menudo con la migración
clandestina pero digamos que hablar de
tráfico de personas es como negar la
voluntad de las personas que quieren
emigrar no cuando hablamos de tráfico es
como si digamos habláramos de mercancías
y en este caso es el señor pues crítica
precisamente que en este caso el
traslado forzoso y en contra de la
voluntad de las personas son estas
expulsiones que ejecuta el gobierno
británico y por otro lado el resto de
las portadas pues del reino unido pues
como decíamos no hacen mucha referencia
a esta cuestión pero coinciden en
destacar estas fotos de ucrania como
decíamos que son de una graduación
escenificada en las ruinas de la ciudad
del norte de este país de ucrania de
eternit que de hecho son de stanislas el
ix para la agencia reuters que vamos a
ver a continuación si te parece
hemos preparado una pequeña selección
con estas imágenes no que es lo que
pretenden es un poco ver ya como si aquí
las tenemos no como la población civil
después de estos meses de guerra digamos
tal y como dice este fotógrafo ya no
muestran al shock por la guerra o su
alrededor no digamos recordemos que es
difícil por un lado establecer el número
de civiles muertos y por otro lado que
ya se está hablando de reconstrucción de
ucrania sin ni siquiera vislumbrar cómo
puede terminar esta guerra rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces como siempre
por toda la información en esta revista
de prensa y pasamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado al día gracias rosa